chief Washington correspondent that's
major Garrett joins us now he is also
the host by the way of the takeout and
debriefing the briefing podcast I like
the name of that major good morning it's
always good to see you now the president
has claimed that we have prevailed at
testing many health experts including
his own say no we're not really at
capacity yet so there seems to be a lot
of mixed messaging here who was right in
this particular circumstance again both
are right there is enough capacity for
phase 1 which means if you are
symptomatic are you a part of contact
tracing you can get tested and we have
ramped up testing capacity in this
country and the administration has the
regulatory means and encouraging
industry and supporting industry and
working with Congress finally money
increased our testing capacity that's
true that's not true but it's not
anywhere near enough and what the
president loves to do is oversimplify
and brand America leads the world in
testing that's a brand you know what
Kovach 19 doesn't care about
oversimplification it just spreads and
to reopen the economy full and you get
to phase 2 phase 3 we need much more
industrial scale testing and we're not
there yet and the simple truth is and
it's one the president simply does not
in public want to recognize is that
without that dramatically increased
testing capacity we cannot confidently
reopen the economy and keep it open
through the summer in the fall why
doesn't he want to recognize that major
it seems so clear to so many other
people who are watching all of this
unfold because it sounds to feed us that
it's not part of the president's sort of
psychic message to the country that we
can reopen and it's time to reopen and
this idea is transitioning to greatness
we can't get to greatness unless you
have a testing capacity well the
president says well we've built it up
we've we've improved over the last three
or four weeks and yes we have improved
but not nearly enough and Gail let's go
to the very specific optics of the White
House they're now wearing masks every
day which they weren't doing a week ago
or two weeks ago there's testing
capacity every single day in the White
House so the average American might
reasonably ask is my house like the
White House no it's not you can't get
tested every day the White House does on
most matters
most days most Americans don't want
their house to be like the White House
it's a regal and special place but in
this case with testing most Americans by
the end of this are going to need that
kind of regular access to testing to
build their own confidence to have
confidence in their workplace to have
confidence when they go to any kind of
event where there are lots of people all
of those things are required to reopen
our economy and be like the old normal
and without testing capacity we simply
cannot get there dr. Anthony foul she is
going to be testifying today remotely
what are you expecting to hear from him
today
well we always hear from dr. Falchi
there are hard truths here that as we
reopen there are going to be more cases
and more deaths let's just look at this
scale really simply on April 27th the
last time there was a task force
briefing about 1700 deaths in their
country 1800 deaths in the country from
Kobe 19 yesterday the projected number
is about 1700 so the death rate is not
changing very much and the case rate
despite what the president says is
rising and dr. pouchy will say what
every public health official has said
the more we reopen the more cases that
are going to be and we have to balance
that risk and doing that is not easy but
one of the things that makes it easier
and more digestible it's clear
consistent messaging from the highest
officials in the land and I think for
this president and this White House that
has proved them very challenging yeah
all right major thank you very much